fumar daña dos de las partes principales
de los pulmones las vías respiratorias
también llamadas tubos bronquiales y los
pequeños sacos de aire llamados alveolos
con cada respiración el aire viaja por
el conducto respiratorio llamado tráquea
y entra en los pulmones a través de los
tubos bronquiales entonces el aire se
dirige a miles de pequeños alvéolos
donde el oxígeno del aire se mueve hacia
el torrente sanguíneo el dióxido de
carbono de desecho sale del torrente
sanguíneo
y minúsculas proyecciones similares al
cabello llamadas cilios revisten los
tubos bronquiales y barren las
sustancias nocivas fuera de los pulmones
el humo del cigarrillo irrita el
revestimiento de los tubos bronquiales
haciendo que se hinchen y produzca
mucosidad
el humo del cigarrillo también hace más
lento el movimiento de sus cilios
provocando que un poco de humo y la
mucosidad permanezcan en los pulmones
mientras usted duerme algunos de los
cilios se logran recuperar y empiezan a
empujar a los contaminantes y el moco
fuera de los pulmones
cuando usted se despierta su cuerpo
trata de expulsar este material tosiendo
repetidamente una condición conocida
como tos de fumador con el tiempo se
desarrolla la bronquitis crónica debido
a que sus cilios dejan de trabajar sus
vías respiratorias se obstruyen con
cicatrices y moco y la respiración se
vuelve difícil sus pulmones son ahora
más vulnerables a otras enfermedades el
humo del cigarrillo también daña los
alvéolos haciendo más difícil el
intercambio de oxígeno y dióxido de
carbono hacia y desde la sangre
con el tiempo muy poco oxígeno puede
llegar a la sangre por lo que usted
puede desarrollar enfisema afección en
la que se respira con dificultad y se
debe usar un tubo de oxígeno en la nariz
para poder respirar
la bronquitis crónica y el enfisema son
conocidos de manera colectiva como
enfermedades pulmonares obstructivas
crónicas o ep
la gp2 es una pérdida gradual de la
capacidad respiratoria que no tiene cura